so we have the graph of an exponential
function here and the function is m of x
and what i want to do is figure out what
is m
of 6 going to be equal to and like
always pause the video and see if you
can work it out
well as i mentioned this is an
exponential function so m is going to
take the form let me write this way m
of x is going to take the form a times r
to the x power
where a is our initial value and r is
our common ratio
well the initial value is pretty
straightforward it's just going to be
what m of 0 is so a is going to be equal
to m of 0 and we can just look at this
graph when x is equal to 0 the function
is equal to 9. so it's equal to 9. and
now we need to figure out our common
ratio so let me set up a little bit of a
table here just to help us with this
so
let me
draw some straight lines
and so this is x and
m of x
we already know that when x is 0 m of x
is equal to 9.
we also know
when x is let's see when x is 1
when x is 1 m of x is 3
m of x is 3.
so when we when we increase our x by one
what happened to our m of x well what
did we have to multiply it by
well to go from nine to three you
multiplied by one third so that's going
to be our common ratio in fact if we
wanted to care what what m of two is
going to be we would multiply by 1 3
again
and m of 2 should be equal to 1.
and we see that right over here m of 2
is indeed equal to 1. so our common
ratio
our common ratio right over here is
equal to one-third so m of x we can
write it as
m of x
is going to be equal to
our initial value a which we already
figured out as
a is a is equal to 9 so it's going to be
9
times our common ratio
times our common ratio 1 3 to the x
power so i was able to figure out the
the formula for our definition for f of
x but that's not what i wanted i just
wanted to figure out what m of 6 is
going to be so we can write down that m
of 6
m of 6 is going to be
9 times 1 over 3
to the 6th power let's see that is going
to be equal to that's the same thing as
9 times well 1 to the 6th is just 1.
it's going to be 1 to the 6 which is
just 1 over 3 to the sixth power
now what is 3 to the 6th power in fact i
could even simplify this a little bit
more i could recognize that 9 is 3
squared so i could say this is going to
be 3 squared over 3 to the sixth
3 squared
over 3
to the sixth
and then
i could tackle this a couple of ways i
could just divide the numerator and the
denominator by 3 squared in which case i
would get 1 over
3 to the 4th power or another way to
think about it this would be the same
thing as 3 to the 2 minus 6 power which
is the same thing as 3 to the negative 4
power which of course is the same thing
as 1 over 3 to the fourth so what's
three to the fourth so three squared is
nine three to the third is 27 three to
the fourth is 81. so this is going to be
equal to one over eighty-one m of six is
equal to one over eighty-one we could
also done that if we kept going by our
table
m of 3 multiplied by 1 3 is going to be
1 3. m of 4 multiplied by 1 3 again is
going to be 1 9. and we could m of 5 is
going to be
and m of 6 is going to be 180 first